all right Michaela
Michaela where are you from originally
Compton California
Compton tell me about your family
growing up I'm the only child of my
mother
seven is on my father's side but I was
raised by my grandmother
yeah
it was a
yeah it was a toxic
family I guess you can say
molested by my grandmother's boyfriend
for three years
when I came out to tell her she didn't
believe me she left with him
for you that was going on well it
happened 9 10 and 11 but I finally came
out and told her at 14.
and when she didn't believe me um to the
streets I ran
you ran away I ran away I started
gangbanging started
doing you know
the unthinkable
boosting stealing pillow posts
um
at one point selling myself or trying to
yeah just
degrading stuff yeah for for a 14 year
old to be on the streets right how are
you going to survive
I didn't know how
I didn't know how I didn't know what to
do
um
some friends I guess you can call them
family members took me in but
Now That I'm Older
I'll I now know that it was like for
ulterior motives like to gain uh some
type of income for me or for me to go
stealing for their household and you
know it was always a motive your dad was
rare he was in the same city but he
didn't want no parts of me he kept my
siblings away from me for whatever
reason I don't know I guess I was a bad
seed
finish High School
uh no I got my GED in prison
are we in prison for
first time or second time
first time armed robbery and the second
time
identity theft
this is at a young age
uh 18 to 20
22. I believe 18 19 21 how do you know
34 34 35 at the end of the month you're
still young
get kids I don't that's good
well just in your situation well yeah in
a situation yeah
it's lonely though
how are you surviving now
um
I don't even know Mark
honestly
I like I live day by day
where'd you sleep
in my truck
that's um broke down
it broke down in L.A and I've been stuck
ever since
you can't move it
and I'm in front of these complexes
these people I don't even know
is yeah it's bad
I go to the Family Dollar down the
street just to use the bathroom every
day
if I make it down there where do you
shower
when I can
well in my backseat water bottles
you look really clean thank you
somebody's sleeping in their car thank
you
I'll try
you have nobody to help you out no
support system
I got my grandma but like I said
um when her boyfriend doing that to me
um
she kind of hates me because like for
everybody yeah she's like the um Miss
Goody Two Shoes so like it was an
embarrassment to her so by me breaking
up her happy home I guess like she hates
me
she just deals with me but she hates me
she'll pay me to stay away
you know it's weird
the drugs are a part of your life and it
was at one point yeah
I am
I started doing crystal meth
and
I don't know why it wasn't nothing to
numb me it was just something to do
and then I got addicted to it
and then that led to addiction to
gambling at one point
and from there everything just went down
I can't like being at the Casitas
yeah Casitas
casinos
scratchers
but mainly the Casitas what is it about
gambling that
is
the urge to make money I I assume in my
head you think you think this is a good
way to make money yeah I thought until
it just started going down down baby but
yeah for me it was an urge to like
make quick money
and that's it's a way to lose money
quick
that ain't even mine that I'm lying to
get that I'm going to the stores
boosting just to make something just to
go gamble it
at an illegal establishment I think it's
ridiculous and sad but I was addicted to
it
I was
what role models did you have when you
were a young girl
I have any
I can't remember any
I don't remember having a dream I don't
know what I want to be
I never
to this day I can't tell you what
my dream consists of
I feel like I'm just here
honestly you're just surviving
barely yeah
emotionally what do you go through oh
depressed of course I'm depressed smart
Prince
lonely
um
that's the main thing because I can't
have kids and um my siblings like I said
we're not close my mom and my dad
for whatever reason
they live we all live in the same city
or around each other like my mom's down
here actually but I haven't seen them in
years
my grandma hates me I just I just I feel
detached from everybody like I don't
understand why
do you have any friends
I got some buddies street street friends
that's it yeah
cosita friends gambling friends boosting
friends
I wouldn't consider them friends
and you said you can't have kids or you
don't have kids I can't have any and I
don't have any you cannot have kids even
if you
that's what I was told I couldn't
that's not the end of the world
with being depressed and living on the
streets
without a way out that is pretty bad
have you been to any like women's
programs or
some of the shelters
I went to a shelter and
I was sodomizing one so I told myself
that I never go to another one because
they didn't try to do nothing to help me
um
I haven't offered them but uh
I just refuse I guess
you feel like you were ever loved
What is love
I hear it quite a few times
relationships
a couple of family members but
what is it like
because what they say
that [__] hurt so I
I don't know
I'm still trying to figure out what love
is
what's your biggest fear now
[Music]
uh
is it okay to say I don't have any
you've been through a lot
I've been through a lot
it's okay to be you're like you've
you've faced everything there is a face
I've been through a lot
I almost
got life in prison
almost being killed
um
I've been molested raped
homeless
there's been days where I didn't know
where my next meal was coming from
um
I've been jumped I mean I've been yeah
I've been through a lot
so it's not too much that I pray for I
fear animals
what's your greatest strength
uh
[Music]
my
my genuine
heart or loyalty that I have
when I do um
come across people
I guess that are good to me
that's great
what does your typical day look like
what do you do
nothing
like
besides
search on the web for some type of
housing
nothing
it's like I don't have a life
I don't have no potential I'm gonna be
35 and I don't have nothing to show for
it like
and I know I know I know I know in my
heart that I'm worth so much more
but for whatever reason I just can't
seem to like get on my feet and like
just go forward it's like I'm stuck in a
box
you feel like life is unfair yes
the
but you went through as a child
kind of sets up yes this you know the
way you feel about yourself now for sure
it is
I don't know you know like Karma you
know you do stuff and then things happen
to you like I was a child I didn't have
that coming
and then to just be left
and not believed
it's like what the [__] I don't know I
don't get it I'm confused
and then even as an adult like
they hate me like or they just
left me like neglected me like what
what could this child do so much to make
their parents like not want to deal with
you or like I'm a mom's only child like
I haven't seen her talk to her in years
what's her situation is she on the
streets as well
it's funny because um before I went to
prison
um I had completed the program and I got
my own place but I had caught a case so
I told her she could stay there so she
wouldn't be on the streets long story
short when I got out she didn't want to
give me my place back
and from she's just
I don't know just stop talking to me
like just pulling me out of my place and
just
said to help I haven't got a happy
birthday in years uh Cardinal nothing
like nothing she talks to my grandmother
on a daily basis but
like they just said [__] me
and I really don't get it
I didn't do anything I never stole from
her like you know I never nothing
I'm confused and it's [__] my head up
my dad got a big ass house somewhere
tell me about Hope do you still have
hope or do you lose hope sometimes
I got hope
I do have hope
I feel like I'm kind of at my lowest
right now and the only place I can go is
up so
I know I'm not a bad person Mark I know
I'm not
I know
it's gonna get better it has to
yeah what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um
I don't know
just I guess remain positive and
continue just
I mean nobody's perfect but just do good
and
what you give out is what you
you know will receive so
I mean like I said I'm not perfect but
you just live and you learn I guess I
don't know
if that makes sense yeah
all right thank you so much I'm sorry
cry baby